this video is brought to you by
Squarespace the tool to use to make a
website for your brand and grow your
business more about them in a bit
George Washington described Nathaniel
Green as a gentleman in whom I placed
the most entire confidence many of his
peers and modern historians considered
him the second best American general in
the Revolutionary War and they also
speculated that green would have assumed
command of the Continental Army if
anything were to happen to George
Washington So today we're going to see
what all the fuss was about as we
explore the life in the military career
oh Nathaniel Greene
[Music]
Nathaniel Green was born on August 7
1742 at Ford farm in Warwick Rhode
Island back then still a part of the
British colonies he was the Second Son
of Nathaniel Greene's senior and his
second wife Mary Mott and he had five
other siblings as well as two older Step
Brothers Nathaniel senior was not only a
successful farmer who came from one of
the oldest families in Rhode Island but
it was also at about preacher with the
religious Society of Friends aka the
Quakers they were Ardent pacifists so
any kind of military action was a strict
No-No causing Nathaniel Greene to
struggle throughout his life to
reconcile his faith with his desire to
fight for an independent America
education was also discouraged among
Quakers back then so a young Nathaniel
was never sent to a proper School
however he was taught to read and write
and he became an Avid Reader who
devoured all the books he could get his
hands on which included non-religious
texts much to his father's Chagrin
despite his objections the Elder green
did not stand in the way of his son's
desire for Higher Learning and hired a
tutor to give him an advanced education
once he was older Nathaniel Green
trained become a blacksmith and worked
at his father's iron Foundry in Warwick
Business wasn't exactly booming but it
was good enough that the family opened
another Forge in Coventry Rhode Island
10 miles south of the farm in 1717
Nathaniel Green relocated to Coventry
permanently to manage the second Forge
that same year he and his siblings
gained complete control of the Family
Estate after their father passed away
for Nathaniel this meant he had gained
the freedom to do something that his
father would have greatly found upon to
study military history and science in
Coventry Green built a new home for
himself a nice two-story house that
sprawled over 83 acres of land which he
named spell Hall a few years after the
move green met Catherine Kitty
Littlefield whose Uncle once served as
governor of Rhode Island the two of them
got itched in 1774 when Nathaniel was 32
years old and kitty was 19 and they went
on to have five children together
Catherine green proved to be very
dedicated to her husband and during the
war she tried to visit him at his
military headquarters whenever possible
she preferred the chaos and danger of
the battlefield to the relative safety
of her estate as long as she was by
Nathaniel's Side Green recognized the
rising tensions between British
officials and American colonists his own
family had an ongoing feud with the
Scottish Admiral named William
duddingston who oh once seized one of
their sloops and confiscated its cargo
the greensfield lawsuits against
darlingston to no avail and then in 1772
a group of men boarded dunningston's
ship the HMS Gatsby ran it aground and
burned it down as a protest against all
the British impositions on the American
colonies naturally many assumed that the
Green family had been involved in this
actual Rebellion they weren't as it
turned out but the Gatsby Affair as it
came to be known served as a pivotal
moment in the lead-up to the American
Revolution as more and more people came
to share Nathaniel Greene's belief that
war between Britain and America had
become an inevitability
Nathaniel Greene first became involved
with the military in 1774 when he helped
organize a militia in Rhode Island known
as the kentish guards word of this
reached back home and got him banished
from his Quaker Community but for green
there was no turning back but despite
his sacrifice and the fact that he
helped put the militia together green
was only offered a modest post as a
private due to Olympiad since childhood
which made him unfit the combat while
this might tank other men's careers
before they even got off the ground it
only proved to be a small lobster of a
green he swallowed his pride and
accepted the position of private
marching three times a week to the beat
of Fife and Drum and even risked being
arrested in order to smuggle a musket
for himself from Boston ultimately it
didn't take long for others to recognize
his innate abilities as a leader even
though he was never able to serve as a
rank and fall Soldier green proved to be
much more valuable as a commander than a
private on April 19th 1775 the battles
of Lexington and Concord signaled the
beginning of the Revolutionary War when
word reached Nathaniel Greene he kissed
his wife goodbye God on his horse and
road to East Greenwich to assemble the
kentish guards at Daybreak the next
morning the guards marched on Providence
where they found out that the fighting
was taking place in Boston where the
British army was under siege by the
colonial militia led by George
Washington a swift meeting of the Rhode
Island and Connecticut assemblies took
place in order to decide how the New
England colonies should respond in a
surprising move the Rhode Island
assembly unanimously elected Nathaniel
Greene to lead the colony's Army even
though the kentish guards had other more
experienced commanders at their disposal
this trust placed in green was
reinforced in June when the Second
Continental Congress convened and
established the Continental Army putting
George Washington in charge of all
Colonial forces they also appointed 16
generals and Nathaniel Green was among
them it took a while before green proved
his medal in combat he was absent from
the most important conflict of the
Boston campaign the Battle of Bunger
Hill because he was in Rhode Island at
the time trying to muster more troops
then during the New York campaign George
Washington placed him in charge of
Brooklyn's defenses but green became
bedridden with a high fever so he had to
relinquish God he missed the Battle of
Brooklyn the second largest Battle of
the entire revolutionary war with 30 000
soldiers engaged in combat probably for
the best since this was a crushing
defeat for the Continental Army that
almost cost Washington his life
Nathaniel Greene finally saw some action
in the following Skirmish the Battle of
Harlem Heights after the British victory
in Long Island they had taken over
Manhattan while the Continental Army had
to retreat to Harlem on September 16th
the British emerged in battle with a
group of colonial Scouts called
knowlton's Rangers who had no choice but
to head back towards the main camp with
the Redcoats in Hot Pursuit Washington
decided to lay a little trap for the
Enemy by sending out a brigade of a
thousand men led by Nathaniel Greene to
meet the opposing Force head-on while a
few regiments worked their way around
the right flank of the British the plan
was to have them emerge behind the enemy
and pin them down between the two forces
but the regiments needed to produce some
work on their timing they turned the
wrong way and came out too early right
in the center of the flank the British
spotted the Trap that was being laid for
them so they retreated in time even
though this was only a minor engagement
it was a victory for the Continental
Army and a sorely needed one at that
since the site of a Redcoats tucking
their tails and turning back served as a
much needed morale Boost after the
failure in Brooklyn following this
battle Nathaniel Greene needed a bit
more down time to fully recover from his
illness so Washington placed him in
command both Fort Washington and Fort
Lee back then known as Fort Constitution
which were on opposite sides of the
Hudson River the former in New York in
the latter in New Jersey at first this
worked out great as the fort served as
valuable Supply Depots but in November
three British ships managed to withstand
the barrage of fire and made it past the
forts allowing the Redcoats to take up
positions on the Hudson River once
Washington heard of this he told green
to abandon Fort Washington fearing that
it had become too vulnerable since it
was located in New York which was under
British control but green was confident
that he would Triumph should the fort be
attacked he wrote back to Washington
words that would haunt him for the rest
of his life upon the whole I cannot help
thinking the Garrison is of advantage
and I cannot conceive The Garrison to be
in any great danger the men can be
brought off at any time later that month
the commander-in-chief of the British
land forces General William Howe decided
to test this belief on November 16 1776
Howe launched a three-pronged attack on
the fort after a heavy barrage of Cannon
far his eight thousand men overwhelmed
The Garrison of only 3 000 Colonial
soldiers who were soon forced to
surrender in the blink of an eye the
Continental Army had lost dozens of
cannons countless supplies and
ammunition and over 2 800 soldiers who
were taken prisoner when he heard of the
devastating defeat George Washington
himself rode the remaining Fort Lee and
ordered green to pack up and leave it
behind for the British forces who
crossed the Hudson and occupied it a few
days later there was no sugar coating
this green screwed the pooch big time
and many people were furious with his
insistence on staying at Fort Washington
there were calls to relieve him of his
command even General Washington was
starting to have doubts about green but
decided against it fortunately for both
men Washington's trust was ultimately
Vindicated not just before we continue
today I got to tell you about a service
that you probably never heard about
before Squarespace just kidding of
course you've heard of Squarespace
everyone has heard of Squarespace and
that's because they're the absolute best
place to build a website in 2022 and
well 2023 pretty soon and they'll be the
best then as well but seriously if you
need a website there is no point
considering anyone else if you ever
thought I need a website for my business
my blog my annoying political opinions
whatever think no more than Squarespace
why because websites are ridiculously
easy to make and ridiculously feature
Rich with Squarespace but imagine the
situation you know nothing about
websites you love looking at them you
know the ones that work and look really
nice but you don't know how to make that
well good news you can make a website
that looks just like that on Squarespace
with ease you don't need any skills
whatsoever and look Squarespace don't
just do blogs which they do beautifully
you can also sell things through
Squarespace which you know is a good
thing if the website you want to make is
a business or maybe you've got other
things in mind in that case they've got
loads of other features email campaigns
analytics social Integrations all that
good stuff you'd expect go to
squarespace.com for a free trial and
when you're ready to launch go to
squarespace.com biographics to save 10
of your first purchase for a website or
a domain and now back to today's video
[Music]
with New York lost the Continental Army
had no choice but to set up camp in
Pennsylvania making Philadelphia its new
headquarters this Arrangement didn't
last long though because the British
captured Philadelphia on September the
11th 1777 following a victory at the
Battle of Brandywine near Chad's Ford
Pennsylvania things weren't looking too
Sunny in Philadelphia for the
Continental Army but it was time for
some personal glory for Nathaniel Green
whose division was instrumental in
preventing the defeat from turning into
a disaster his unit acted as a rear
guard that held off the enemy long
enough for the rest of the army to
retreat to safety and to live to fight
another day this Act of Valor was
preceded by two more victories in New
Jersey there weren't anything major but
taken together they were enough for
Green's reputation to recover following
the black eye received Fort Washington
this conflict was soon followed by the
Battle of Germantown on October 4th back
then Germantown was a hamlet outside of
Philadelphia proper where Howe decided
to move the bulk of his army roughly 9
000 soldiers while only a Garrison of
three thousand was left to guard
Philadelphia Washington hoped that an
unexpected attack could destroy the main
British force and possibly compel the
rest to abandoned Philadelphia the plan
always to use the element of surprise to
trap the red coats in a flanking
maneuver General George Sullivan was in
command of the main line when Nathaniel
Green attacked the Left Flank and
General William Smallwood commanded a
militia as that would cover the extreme
right and rear unfortunately things
didn't go as planned and this time it
was Mother Nature that conspired against
the Continental Army heavy fog caused
Green's unit to get lost and Enter The
Fray half an hour after the battle had
already started delays and poor
communication tipped off the enemy and
allowed them to occupy fortified
positions resulting in another heavy
loss for the Americans that went up the
Continental Army camped at Valley Forge
about 20 miles Northwest of Philadelphia
it was a desolate wretched location
described by Washington as a dreary kind
of place and uncomfortably provided the
caused the death of around 2 000
soldiers due to starvation exposure or
diseases such as typhus and smallpox
following the harsh and deadly winter
Washington all wanted somebody knew in
charge of the quartermaster department
and offered Nathaniel Green the position
of quartermaster General giving him the
responsibility of supplying the
continental army green didn't exactly
see this as a promotion feeling that it
was a nearly impossible task to avoid of
any Glory he wrote in a letter all of
you will be immortalizing yourselves in
the golden pages of History while I am
confined to a series of drudgery to pave
the way for it to Washington himself
green put it more bluntly nobody ever
heard of a quartermaster in history even
so Nathaniel Greene still did what
Washington asked of him and he did it
well he reorganized the quartermaster
Corps established new supply lines and
sent his men on foraging missions to
bolster Their Food Supplies but he
missed life on the front lines and he
asked to be given command of his troops
again in order to quell his lust for
Action Washington allowed green to take
part in two battles in the summer of
1778. first was the Battle of Monmouth
in New Jersey and then the Battle of
Rhode Island in Green's own neck of the
woods neither battle had a decisive
finish but the latter did allow green to
travel to his home estate back in
Coventry and enjoy some much-needed r r
with his family and it was perfectly
timed too because afterward came the
golden opportunity for green to really
show what he was made of
the year 1778 was a turning point in the
war for starters France Allied itself
with the United States in February the
British abandoned Pennsylvania and
withdrew back to New York allowing the
Continental Army to retake Philadelphia
in the summer with both sides entrenched
in a solid position the northern theater
became somewhat of a stalemate while the
serious action had moved to the southern
colonies primarily Georgia Virginia and
the Carolinas for the first couple of
years of combat in the southern theater
it was the same old song and dance for
America the Continental Army won a few
and lost a few including a disgraceful
loss at Camden where the Americans had
the Tactical advantage and twice the
soldiers yet the inept command of Major
General Horatio Gates led to a
humiliating defeat up until that point
Gates had been somewhat of a golden boy
with some of his supporters even a
pining that he should command the
Continental Army instead of Washington
however after that ludicrous display
last battle where Gates just tried to
walk it in it was not only relieved of
his position but he barely avoided a
core martial naturally somebody else had
to take over Washington was still busy
up north trying to take New York with
the help of the French and he saw no man
better suited for the job than Nathaniel
Greene in a letter Washington wrote in
my absence the command of the army
devolves upon you I have so entire
confidence in your prudence and
abilities that I leave the conduct of it
to your discretion and so on October 14
1790 Nathaniel Green was named the new
commander of the Southern continental
army becoming second only to Washington
himself in early December green reached
the main camp located in Charlotte North
Carolina where he soon discovered that
he had his work cut out for him he had a
skeleton of an army few supplies and not
a lot of help coming from Congress
meanwhile the enemy had greater numbers
better training better positions and was
lured by a skilled military commander
named General Charles Cornwallis Greene
realized that barring some kind of
meteor crash or divine intervention he
didn't have the ghost of a chance for
success in pitched battle so instead he
relied on guerrilla warfare launching
small-scale sudden attacks that were
over before the British army had a
chance to recover and retaliate these
proved successful but then green took an
even bigger risk and divided his army in
two taking the bulk of his forces with
him while a smaller division was left
under the command of Brigadier General
Daniel Morgan as he hoped Cornwallis did
the same with his own Army and went in
pursuit of green while a smaller Force
Under Colonel benastra Tarleton went
after Daniel Morgan first the two
smaller armies met in combat at the
Battle of the cow pens on January 17
1781 which proved to be a resounding
victory for the American side although
both forces had a little over a thousand
soldiers Morgan sustained only a few
dozen casualties whereas the British
army led by Tarleton was almost entirely
taken out of action afterward Morgan
reunited with Nathaniel Green who was
still leading Cornwallis on a chase
through the southern colonies with the
end goal being to get him as far as
possible from his main Supply base in
Charleston South Carolina this brought
on the so-called a race to the Dan
referring to the Dan River that passes
through North Carolina and Virginia
again green separated a small force of
700 men led by Colonel Arthur Williams
to lead Cornwallis on a wild goose chase
away from the main Army led by Green
himself so that he could safely cross
the river and Retreat into Virginia for
resupply and reinforcements and prepare
for an all-out battle komolis fell for
Green's decoy Hook Line and Sinker he
chased Williams and his men for three
days covering 200 balls all while
thinking that he was closing in on the
main enemy force and was getting ready
to go in for the kill by the time a
red-faced Cornwallis realized he'd been
had it was too late green was in
Virginia and for the first time since he
took over the southern Army he had a
decent Army of 4 200 well-equipped
motivated men with no Alternatives the
British retreated to North Carolina now
is the time to strike green and
Cornwallis finally clashed at the Battle
of Guildford courthouse in Greensboro
North Carolina on March 15 1781.
technically the British won the
battlefield but this was somewhat of a
peric victory since a quarter of
cornwallis's men had been killed injured
or captured prompting British Statesman
Charles James Fox to later that another
such a victory would ruin the British
army meanwhile Nathaniel Greene managed
to withdraw from the batter with his
forces mostly intact accomplishing his
main goal of debilitating the enemy Army
and forcing them to regroup after this
battle the British abandoned the
Carolina campaign ceding control of
North Carolina back to the Americans
komolis and green went their separate
ways as the latter chose to fight in
South Carolina and Georgia instead of
following Cornwallis into Virginia what
followed was a series of battles known
collectively as the war of the posts
where green concentrated his efforts on
enemy fortifications in order to weaken
the British grasp on the southern
colonies no earthy clashes included the
Battle of hobkirks Hilt the month-long
Siege in South Carolina known as The
Siege of 96 and the Battle of Utah
Springs Green's campaign was a classic
case of something greater than the sum
of its parts taken in isolation none of
the battles were particularly impressive
but together they represented a constant
and successful effort to chip away at
the British forces to the point where
they had to abandon the interior of the
southern colonies and Retreat to the
coast to Charleston Nathaniel Greene
basically ensured that as long as his
compatriots did their bit up in the
north the British would have no place in
the South where they could regroup and
launch a new attack and spoiler alert
the northern continental army led by
Washington held up attended the bargain
effectively winning the war at Yorktown
following a three-week Siege against the
forces of Charles Cornwallis which
prompted the British general to
surrender to George Washington on
October 19 1781.
the Revolutionary War still carried on
for over a year and a half after
Yorktown officially ending on September
3 1783 following the Treaty of Paris
with the war over Nathaniel Green
resigned his commission and also turned
down several appointments within
Washington's new government including as
America's first Secretary of War it
seemed like green was looking forward to
some quality time with his family but he
still left a few pressing matters to
settle oddly enough even though he was a
hero of the Revolution green had money
troubles he had ended the war in heavy
debt because he personally guaranteed
expenses used to supply his men
fortunately for him he also received
several grants of land and money from
the southern colonies as thanks for his
efforts during the war the state
legislature of Southern Carolina gifted
him ten thousand guineas and another
five thousand guineas came from North
Carolina and thousands of acres of land
came from Georgia finally in late 1785
green had resolved his financial woes
and settled at his new Plantation called
Mulberry Grove in Georgia a letter he
wrote in April 1786 showed his
satisfaction with Farm Life The Garden
is delightful the fruit trees and
flowering shrubs form a pleasant variety
we have green bees almost fit eaten as
fine lettuce as you ever saw the
Mockingbirds surround us evening and
morning the weather is mild and the
vegetable World progressing to
Perfection we have in the same Orchard
apples pears peaches apricots nectarines
plums of various kinds figs pomegranates
and oranges and we have strawberries
which we measure three inches around
unfortunately for green he did not get
to enjoy his new peaceful Life along he
died just two months after writing that
letter he fell ill on June the 12th due
to sunstroke while visiting a friend's
rice fields he was taken home but he
never recovered Nathaniel Greene died on
June the 19th 1786 at the age of 43. his
family continued living at Mulberry
Grove and during the early 1790s his
widow took in a tutor for her children
his name was Eli Whitney and he ended up
inventing the cotton gin during his time
spent at the plantation
foreign